I think that Simon is a brilliant
economist and essay that he wrote in the
Atlantic was terrific as it happened
Simon and I have known each other for a
long time and share a background in
being involved me reporting Simon as an
economist and the collapse of the former
Soviet Union and I think that it was
that mindset which shaped Simon's
intellectual response and and offered
him a prism through which to look at the
relationships between government and the
big banks here and see III think that
Simon would absolutely agree that
there's not the sort of crony capitalism
here that you would see in Russia but
but to see some similarities one thing
that I think has become much clearer in
the wake of the crisis which was maybe
not so apparent beforehand is the extent
to which intellectually we were
ill-equipped to really understand the
dynamics of what we're going on in the
developed Western capitalist economies
and I do think that one of the things
which happened was with the collapse of
communism a lot of us and not just
people who had a vested financial
interest in this but also academics
journalists policymakers a lot of us
really bought into for the best of
possible reasons the sort of end of
history argument the Francis Fukuyama
view that this big economic question
which was the big question of the 20th
century of what sort of economic system
do you want a communist system or
capitalist system had been definitively
answered by the collapse of the Soviet
Union and arguably by China's effective
embrace of a market economy as well and
I think I think that's right I I think
that
big question has been answered but I
think what we then collectively tended
to do is assume therefore that questions
of political economy were no longer so
central and that it wasn't so important
in thinking about the economic rules of
the game to think about you know those
very basic even sort of Marxist
questions about who benefits and who
loses from any particular economic setup
I think what we tended to start thinking
the intellectual toolkit which we used
in thinking about economic decisions was
really more engineering and we started
to think that the big questions were
going to be resolved just by sort of
smart people getting together figuring
out what works best and that that was
the way that sort of very pragmatic
approach was going to be the way that
big economic questions got resolved I
think there's still something to that
and certainly you know when we write
editorials in the Financial Times that's
the sort of approach which we tried to
have but what I think we collectively
stopped thinking about was stopped
really properly focusing on was that
when these big issues would legislation
about financial regulation for example
gets actually hammered out by
legislators political economy enters
into it and it's incredibly important to
be thinking about which particular
interests which particular companies are
going to benefit from this version of
the law and which companies are going to
benefit from that version of the law and
it would be absolutely naive not to
appreciate that that's what lobbyists
are for and also naive not to appreciate
that as companies become bigger and more
powerful they have more resources to
throw into that long being game I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
that's democratic politics every
one ought to and and does long before
their own interests but I do think that
we as business journalists and I would
also say the community of economists
need to factor into the equation a
little bit more this notion this
appreciation of the fact that when there
are debates for example over the
regulation of credit derivatives I think
that's the hottest one in this space
right now it's not purely about
intellectually opposing points of view
it's also about players on different
sides of the debate standing to make or
lose a very great deal of money and we
fail our readers legislators fail their
voters when they don't make clear that
this particular way of regulating this
particular market will make Bank X much
much richer and maybe will carry the
collective costs of y&z
I would diss
with part of Scott's premise which is
first of all implicit in the question is
the notion that we were in a period that
we are in a period of deflation and also
implicit in the question is that a lot
of the unconventional tools of monetary
policy weren't used I do think actually
a lot of unconventional tools of
monetary policy were used and one of the
most creative players in the crisis
turns out to have being Ben Bernanke
with Mervyn King not too far behind so
we did have we did have and continue to
have all sorts of unconventional forms
of liquidity being injected into the
markets by the world's central bankers
now that you know once they hit that
zero rate where they couldn't use
interest rates to gin up the economy we
have seen them using many many
unconventional tools to try to pump more
money into the economy so actually I do
think we have seen all sorts of
unconventional monetary policy responses
and I do also think certainly
journalists at the financial times are
very well aware of you know the two
economic arms that government has
monetary policy and fiscal policy and I
think we've written with real
sophistication about the monetary debate
and then also about the fiscal debate so
actually I think both that we've had
more creative monetary policies than as
Scott would imply in his question but
also that at the moments of decision I
think that we were quite thoughtful and
explicit in talking about what those
options were
I think to assess the links between the
Obama administration and business is a
really big really complicated question
and in some ways it's still too early to
answer it they haven't been in office
for a full year and I think that there
are different questions that need to be
asked about the Obama administration in
different areas so there's one set of
issues in health care there's one set of
issues in the environment and climate
change and there's one set of issues in
financial services to take financial
services I think that they're really you
know fairness requires that we divide
the response of the Obama administration
into two parts the first is the
immediate crisis firefighting and there
I think we really have to be careful not
to apply the rules of calmness of the
markets having recovered of the Second
Great Depression no longer seeming to be
a possibility that might start tomorrow
we have to be careful not to apply that
mindset to the decisions that were taken
in the crisis and we also have to be
mindful of the fact that the really big
decisions of both the financial crisis
were all taken when George Bush was
still president now it is true that
Barack Obama made the explicit choice
effectively to carry on with those
policies by promoting Tim Geithner from
being the head of the New York Fed to
being his secretary of the Treasury even
so the big decisions were already in
place where I think the Obama
administration has a much clearer much
freer choice to make in its relationship
with the banking industry is the
post-crisis is what the regulatory and
legislative response is to this crisis
and there we haven't yet seen I think a
very robust response yet we had a choice
by the White House to
move on health care before moving on
financial reform and in financial reform
we have not yet seen a sufficiently in
my view aggressive response I do think
that the right thing for this
administration for any administration to
do is to say actually the rules of the
game were a real problem ahead the
financial crisis and while before this
crisis maybe people reasonable people
could legitimately disagree about the
extent to which markets self-regulate
this crisis really is proof that they
can't self-regulate and that booms and
busts still do happen and most
importantly that the collective cost of
those booms and busts is really great
and that is what gives government a
right and indeed a responsibility to
regulate in such a way that minimizes
both the likelihood of those booms and
busts and more importantly the
collective costs of those booms and
busts and I think the responsibility of
government to do that absolutely
outweighs both the growth penalty
because if you do have regulation that
does inevitably cut down on innovation
and it means that in your boom period
your boom is a little bit less vigorous
and it also really means that government
has a right to restrict the ability to
grow of specific players and of specific
firms